[Music]
so gorgeous how are you feeling feeling
good darling how are you feeling
fabulous now you're here the gloves have
officially begun
congratulations this is your first
Golden Globe nomination how are you
celebrating tonight
Portsmouth third trip here at my first
nomination because technically the song
that I did with Whitney when you believe
what an Oscar but I was not a writer and
I rest her soul it was not one of the
writers of that song and as a songwriter
this is like a huge honor and especially
as a female we don't always get
acknowledged as songwriters so that kind
of goes with tonight's theme now the
first time you showed the twins the star
how did they react they loved it they
loved the movie I think it's just such a
good movie for kids for families it's
really good and I'm honored to been able
to work with Marc Shaiman was just an
incredible musician and fantastic
songwriter and we work together on this
song called the star and here we are at
the quotes ominously stunning you're
wearing black why was important for you
to support the movement well of course
is important for it as a woman to
support the movement there's no way I
couldn't and I you know I had a few
conversations with Mary Washington
the second or the whole thing and even
like in the music business we haven't
even touched that goal wax I'm gonna
call I don't know what it is but I think
I need to be a consultant when it's time
to talk about that
[Music]